you j'espère que vous allez bien
alors il est possible que certains
d'entre vous se demandent pourquoi y ait
une vidéo le dimanche toute seule je dis
perspicace normal eh bien c'est ce que
peut vous présenter une nouvelle série
il y aura sur la chaîne s'appelle une
image une histoire en gros l'histoire en
raw l'histoire s'il ya quelques mois
avant les vacances d'été
lcm liquid du bois et qui m'a dit cyrus
sont partis pour au rendez vous de
l'histoire à blois à nouveau l'histoire
c'est un gros truc ça touche 4000
personnes c'est à bois ça chaque année
et plein d'historiens qui se retrouvent
etc
il ya des conférences on ya participé je
souhaite nota bene y avait ma nombril il
ya notamment un truc qui s'appelait le
marathon des images il y avait une
soixantaine d'historiens qui se
relayaient et qui montrait genre une
image pendant à peu près cinq minutes et
qui à partir de cette image nous
expliquer des trucs en histoire et sur
ce qu'on peut voir sur cette image là
pourquoi elle était importante
quels sont les symboles qui a derrière
et cetera et cetera et là vous demandez
peut-être moi pas être le marathon des
images ce que je paye syrien et parce
que je panarabe et bien fait l'idée
c'est que de temps en temps au cours du
marathon on diffusait vidéo avec un donc
un autre format qui reprenait une image
du marasme
mon but faire ses vidéos et ses vidéos
la ga soit elles vont sortir un dimanche
sur deux sur cette chaîne donc j'ai
filmé un petit peu et voilà ça ressemble
à ça c'était super chouette alors pour
moi c'est hyper intéressant parce qu'en
fait c'est cher
plein de trucs pour chaque vidéo j'étais
en relation avec un historien ou une
historienne jamais appris plein de
choses et en fait
buts m mieux en image possible son
discours chaque vidéo fait entre deux
minutes trente et trois minutes sans
compter le générique est donc on s'est
demandé où est ce qu'on met les diffuser
ensuite sur internet nous aider que le
mieux c'était peut-être là où j'ai le
plus de monde possible donc sur ma
chaîne dont je suis très content de
poids vous le diffuser alors j'espère
que vous allez apprendre autant de
choses que moi c'est un format qui
change de d'habitude c'est un format qui
est moins je fais un peu moins de voilà
ya moins de bévues que c'est très court
et que c'est très intéressant je romps
passagers que sinon ça va être peut-être
fait trop basse a été trop bref voilà
j'espère que ça va vous plaire le
premier épisode va commencer dans
quelques instants
cette série elle est en plus de tout le
reste on se revoit jeudi pour une
prochaine vidéo très spéciale également
aujourd'hui on va parler non pas
seulement d'une image mais d'une vidéo
choisie par l'historien christian delage
et grâce à son travail
on va comprendre comment cette vidéo a
été le point de départ de la
médiatisation des violences policières
contre la communauté africaine
américaine aux états unis
[Musique]
nous sommes le 3 mars 1991 à los angeles
rodney king and africa américain est
arrêté par des policiers pour excès de
vitesse pour l'obliger à sortir de sa
voiture
une policière pointe une arme sur lui
car il semble en état d'ivresse
king obtempère mais quatre officiers le
plaque alors au sol et lui inflige deux
coupes d'azf et 56 coups de bâton
résultats mâchoire fracturée et cheville
droite cassée mais à quelques mètres de
là georges holiday un voisin témoin de
la scène a le réflexe de filmer ce qui
se passe avec sa nouvelle caméra sonné 8
mm immortalisant les coups portés à ron
les kings un an plus tard en 1992
pendant le procès intenté aux policiers
le procureur tailgate considère que la
vidéo est l'élément de preuve centrale
et déclare alors au grand jury
cette bande vidéo montre de façon
décisive ce qui s'est passé cette nuit
là c'est quelque chose qui ne peut être
réfuté tout le monde peut le constater
c'est l'élément de preuve le plus
objectif qu'on puisse avoir
à la surprise générale la défense
s'empare aussi de la vidéo et décide
d'en faire un élément de preuve à
décharge
c'est à dire de l'utiliser pour
innocenter les policiers sauf qu'au lieu
de projeter devant la cour et les jurés
les images de la vidéo en mouvement
christian delage nous explique que la
défense choisit de les découper en image
fixe qui décomposent les gestes des
policiers en les associant un par un au
comportement prescrit par le manuel du
los angeles police department
le jury majoritairement blanc déclare
alors les policiers non coupable c'est
quelque chose qui a du mal à être
accepté par le public et notamment par
la communauté africaine américaine
en conséquence de quoi d'importantes
émeutes éclatent à los angeles et la
vidéo devient virale le 1er mai 1992 le
président des états unis george bush
donne son opinion sur ce procès après ça
un deuxième procès est ouvert et les
policiers sont finalement condamné
depuis les policiers acceptent d'être
équipé de caméras pendant leur travail
mais ni les caméras ni les images de
vidéos amateurs m'ont prévenu ou
sanctionner les comportements des
policiers et récemment les violences
policières
parfois meurtrières se sont même
multipliés merci à christian delage qui
nous a permis de faire cette vidéo et à
bientôt pour une nouvelle image sur une
image une histoire